[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is sky news today it's one o'clock
the headlines another attempt by nato
leaders to avert a bigger confrontation
with russia as ukraine's president
pleads for more military help you can
give us one percent from all your planes
one percent
of all your tanks just one percent
we'll shortly be live in brussels where
the alliance's director general will
give an update on any new support
as ukraine claims its navies destroyed a
russian ship a diplomat's warning that
moscow could press the nuclear button if
provoked if russia is provoked by nato
if russia is attacked by nato i don't
know
so we are we are nuclear power
also this lunch time the chief executive
of pno apologizes to 800 sacked workers
and admits breaching the law by failing
to consult unions
can i start please with an apology
actually an apology
to
the seafarers that were affected on
thursday last week
an apology
to their families
the biggest fall in living standards on
record but the chancellor insists his
measures will help those who need it
most and profound sorrow for slavery but
no outright apology from prince william
as he continues his royal tour in the
caribbean
[Music]
give us just one percent of your tanks
that's the plea from ukraine's president
today as he addressed nato members
meeting in brussels it's been exactly
one month since since russia's invasion
of ukraine and with no end in sight to
the war western leaders are trying to
avert a possible nuclear confrontation
with russia
there are signs though that ukraine is
beginning to go on the counter-offensive
nato estimates that 7 to 15 000 russian
troops have been killed in the past
month by comparison 15 000 russians died
over an entire decade in afghanistan
the uk's expanded sanctions to 65 more
businesses and individuals including the
stepdaughter of the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov who lives in
london
and president zielinski has called for
nato to provide effective and
unrestricted support and warned that
russia had access to unlimited weapons
of mass destruction
you can give us one percent from all
your planes one percent of all your
tanks just one percent we cannot just
buy that such
supplies
depend on a political decision of nato
please never never tell us that our army
doesn't meet the nato standards we have
demonstrated what our standards are
capable of
how much we can give for
europe's security and the world security
how can we how much we can do to defend
the world against aggression
by the way today they used phosphorus
bombs russian phosphorus bombs
they killed more adults and more
children
arriving at the summit this morning
boris johnson accepted that more needed
to be done to help ukraine defend itself
we've got to step up we've got to
increase our support we've got to
tighten the economic vice around putin
sanctioning more people today as we are
sanctioning the wagner group looking
what we can do to
stop putin using his gold reserves but
also doing more to help the ukrainians
defend themselves that's what we're
doing we're helping of free people to
defend themselves and we're moving
really from a a program of uh supporting
resistance to supporting ukrainian
defense of their own country
nato has been clear that it will not
enforce a no-fly zone but its secretary
general insists the defense alliance is
taking action
we are united in condemning the
kremlin's unprovoked aggression
and in our support for ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
we are determined to continue to impose
costs on russia to bring about the end
of this brutal war we also address
nato's efforts to strengthen
our defenses
now and for the years to come
we are already doing more on land at sea
and in the air this is necessary to
respond to new security reality in
europe
we will hear by the way from secretary
general stoltenberg any minute now we
are awaiting that live press conference
and our deputy political editor sam
coates is uh also
in brussels very busy day sam uh what is
the latest
well we're waiting as you say to find
out what was concluded by the 30 or so
nato leaders who've been meeting this
morning boris johnson opposite president
macron of france joe biden of the us and
olive schultz of germany
to find out whether or not the nato
alliance is delivering uh what president
zielenski asked for in that passionate
address that you heard some of just now
now what zelensky said was quite
important he didn't reiterate that call
we understand for a no-fly zone instead
he asked for very specific equipment one
percent of your planes one percent of
your tanks is what he asked for in a
video address with the nato leaders now
boris johnson told us this morning that
britain is already stepping up to the
plate six thousand more weapons uh just
under 100 million pounds additional aid
for ukraine uh and he very much having
spoken to president zelinski and
yesterday wants to put the pressure on
other western leaders to do more uh some
western leaders more reluctant than
others particularly when it comes to
sanctions
boris johnson making clear today
that he's going after the as it were
militia army of president putin the
wagner group now they are
thought to be the uh individuals the
military group military force going
after president zielinski personally uh
boris johnson will call on other world
leaders to increase their sanctions as
well uh has it worked well that's
exactly what we're hoping to find out
about when we get to the press
conference uh led by jen soltenberg the
un uh the nato secretary general uh
which should be starting uh anytime soon
and we will go to it live uh when it
does uh begin sam coats for now thank
you so much let's go to ukraine and
speak to sky sally lockwood who's in the
vive in the west of the country and
sadly many years there no doubt we'll be
listening in to what nato has to
announce uh any minute now
well i think uh in the west one assumes
that that may be the case but certainly
from some of the refugees that we've
spoken to here at lev
uh train station in western ukraine they
have far bigger things to worry about
we've just spoken to
a family who've arrived here from the
southern city of mariopol which of
course has been
devastated in the last few weeks three
generations of women from one family a
grandmother a mother and a granddaughter
they are absolutely exhausted we're
talking about people who've been without
power without
food largely for weeks now
and a lot of them have been without
internet it's not until they've been
they they've got here they've got
outside of mario pole uh and managed to
get to somewhere safe that they've even
been able to understand the sort of
thing that's going on that the capital
kiev hasn't fallen as so many assumed
would happen at the beginning of this
war
uh and
so i think the diplomacy that's going on
in brussels today while hugely important
we're talking about a country that's
been through immense trauma in the last
month a quarter of the country have been
made
homeless and certainly i think right now
survival
is their primary concern we also spoke
to a family from her son a city in the
north of ukraine a mother who's arrived
here with her three children and she did
say though that she would like to see
more western support in terms of closing
the skies over ukraine as people have
have come to describe it that no-fly
zone that president zielenski has called
on
nato to impose time and time
again and why is that well while the
ground offensive may have stalled here
by russian troops they've certainly
failed in in many areas it's not been
the ground offensive that president
putin i'm sure
imagined uh russian forces haven't even
made it inside uh the capital kiev yet
and indeed in some areas ukrainian
forces have actually
retaken ground but airstrikes are what
is concerning people the most here in
ukraine now you just need to look at
that southern city of mario pole which
has been absolutely
devastated a humanitarian disaster
unfolding
in the south of the country there the
bombings described
as war crimes but one thing that i
should also mention is that we haven't
yet had an air raid siren today and i i
don't believe we had one last night
either the train station here
in la viv in western ukraine which has
seen tens of thousands of families
passing through it in search of safety
in recent weeks is far quieter today
there certainly seems to be perhaps less
panic in ukraine
perhaps they've seen that the russian
advance has stalled has failed there is
certainly a sense of confidence here
despite the chaos despite the trauma and
all these millions of people who've been
made homeless by this war there is a
sense of confidence that ukraine will
come through this the big question is at
what cost
sally lockwood thank you so much
a senior russian diplomat has told sky
news that russia retains the right to
use nuclear weapons if provoked by nato
dmitry polyansky russia's deputy
ambassador to the un also said the
country was not committing war crimes in
ukraine despite the mounting evidence
here's our u.s correspondent martha
kellner
this is one of very few places left in
new york where this man would still be
welcome
it's here at the russian mission to the
un where its leading diplomats write
their speeches where they work out how
on earth to defend the indefensibles
vladimir putin's personal spokesperson
said that russia retains the right to
use nuclear weapons and to defend the
country whatever that may be from
whatever inventory if russia is provoked
by nato if russia is attacked by nato i
don't know
so we are we are nuclear power
why not you think that's a legitimate
thing to be saying though i don't think
it's the right thing to be seeing but
though it's not the right thing to
to to threaten russia and to try to
interfere so
when you're dealing with the nuclear
power of course you have to calculate
all the possible outcomes of of your
behavior that's what i'm going to say
but is russia committing more crimes in
ukraine i don't think we're committing
war crimes in ukraine of course it's not
up to me to to assess i'm not there
you're not there you're looking at the
videos you're looking at the
the uh many videos who are considered to
be fake news are you saying that that
civilian
homes playgrounds hospitals theaters
have not been targeted by russia
they were not targeted
and you know it's very well we said from
the very beginning
that our military is not the threat for
civilian population ukraine can i show
you what the u.s believes is evidence of
war crimes these are pictures taken by
our colleagues
associated press independent news site
these are apartments
on fire in mario paul hit by russian
missiles uh how do you know it's russian
missiles
because there is a cell defense is your
suggestion that
ukrainians
you i will the
it can it can uh it can easily come from
ukraine from the center of the city it
happened in harkov it happened in
mariupol because they have their own
missile
launchers
and a lot of cases that i know are
reported from ukrainian missiles
themselves ambassador with respect i
think that's preposterous like the idea
that this man of this amount of
destruction i think is quite logical
it's not preposterous
mr polyansky may not believe russia is
guilty of war crimes but the u.s says
they are the international criminal
court will ultimately decide but with
every wild claim being made by its
diplomats russia becomes increasingly
isolated on the world stage martha
kellner sky news new york there are a
lot of pictures that have sent me as
well
martha kellner there let's get the
latest uh analysis of the situation on
the ground in ukraine general sir
richard barrens joins me now general
richard very uh good afternoon to you
and and of course nato are meeting as we
speak so we just wanted to start with a
a little snapshot here uh of the ukraine
at the nato members uh
in blue and just
ask the question what's probably top of
the agenda in the discussions that
they've been having over the last few
hours so this is an emergency meeting to
talk about ukraine and there are there
are two important dimensions to this
conversation the most important in the
longer term is how nato now re-mobilizes
itself to deal with russia under
president putin in a way that is the
most significant change since the end of
the cold war in 1990 and the second
thing they're going to do just as
important is talk about nato support to
ukraine in terms of more sanctions and
military support on the topic of uh
military support if we just dive in a
little bit closer but still with uh uh
the nato neighbors uh clearly in shots
some announcements that that have
started to come out some that are
expected in terms of reinforcements yes
so nato is going to affirm today it's
going to deploy four more battle groups
it has battle groups already deployed
across nato in one each to slovakia
hungary romania and bulgaria and they're
a sign of nato assurance and a signal
that article 5 remains in violet and now
let's dive in a little bit to get some
perspectives of what's going on on the
ground uh in ukraine first of all
a focused dive on kiev itself and we
have heard relatively encouraging
stories of some successful
counter-attacks by ukrainian forces in
and around kiev are those significant
generals richard so so they are
significant but they're very small scale
so we know of successful ukrainian
contracts for example in europe and
butcher and also actually to the east of
kiev and these are very small tactical
actions but they are indicative of the
russian forces are not breaking into
kiev and indeed in many places are
moving back a little and starting to
build defensive positions and that feels
like another signal of this evolving
stalemate let's uh talk about that cell
mate if we zoom out and look at uh all
of uh ukraine we've been talking that
these red shaded areas the land that
russia has seized haven't changed
drastically over the last week the
fourth week of this war the stalemate is
is that a very good thing uh for ukraine
or does it get russia time to to refuel
both literally and metaphorically well
both of those things are are true i
think is is i think the signs are right
now that the russian campaign in its
current construction is not capable of
taking much more ground and we're
beginning to see russia dig in these
defensive positions which would indicate
that it it realizes that that does not
mean that that will be the outcome
because russia is moving reinforcements
from across russia both men and materiel
in order to unlock that stalemate but
we're seeing uh not much movement around
kiev we're seeing the battle for mario
poll which i i we imagine um they will
in the end uh break we have not seen the
significant movement towards odessa that
we were forecasting a week ago but we
couldn't rule it out and we are
concerned about russian forces moving
from the north and the south of the
country once mario paul is concluded in
order to try and circle ukrainian forces
in the in the donbass but what this
begins to feel like is a war confined to
the east of ukraine except for
continuing air and missile attacks in
the west on the supply lines but this is
not the war russia intended to have
general sir richard baron sir thanks so
much for that summary of what's going on
on the ground uh on this uh fourth week
of the war
the ukrainian government says seven
humanitarian corridors have been agreed
today but there's still no safe passage
out of the city of mariopol tens of
thousands of people are trapped there
without food water or medicine and life
is extremely difficult our correspondent
sally lockwood spoke to one mother who
has managed to escape
the city of mario paul is almost totally
destroyed
in its ashes or at least a hundred
thousand people trapped and trying to
stay alive
but it's feared there could be far more
than that
uh let's interrupt that and go live now
to brussels uh that nato press
conference with secretary general jens
stoltenberg starting good afternoon we
have just finished an extraordinary
summit
of nato leaders to address the biggest
threat to our security in a generation
president putin's war against ukraine
the people of ukraine are assisting with
the courage and determination
fighting for the freedom
and for their future
we stand with them
presidency addressed us with an
impassioned message
thanking nato allies for the significant
support we are providing
and stressing the vital importance of
even more military assistance
today
nato leaders agreed that we must
and will provide further
support to ukraine
we will continue to impose unprecedented
costs on russia
and we will reinforce
allied deterrence and defence
leaders approved
our four new battle groups in bulgaria
hungary romania and slovakia
these are in addition to the four
already in the baltic countries and
poland
so we have eight
multinational nato battlegroups
now from the
baltic sea to the black sea
across europe there are 100 000 us
troops
supporting nato efforts
and european allies and canada have also
stepped up
we have 40 000 forces under direct nato
command
mostly in the eastern part of the
alliance
backed by
major air and naval power
including an unprecedented five carrier
strike groups
from the high north to the mediterranean
today nato leaders agreed to reset our
returns and defence for the longer term
to face a new security reality
on land
we will have substantially more forces
in the eastern part of the alliance
at higher redness
with more pre-positioned equipment and
supplies
in the air
we will deploy more jets and strengthen
our integrated air and missile defense
at sea
we will have
carrier strike groups
submarines
and significant numbers of combat ships
on a persistent basis
we will also strengthen our cyber
defenses
and enhance our exercises
focusing on collective defense
and interoperability
expect we will decide on the details at
our next summit in madrid in june
today
allah leaders also agreed to provide
further support to ukraine
helping to uphold their fundamental
right to self-defense
allies are also equipping ukraine with
significant military supplies
including anti-tank and air defense
systems and drones
which are proving highly effective
as well as substantial financial and
humanitarian aid
today we agreed to do more
including cyber security assistance
and equipment to help ukraine protect
against biological chemical radiological
and nuclear threats
this could include detection
protection and medical supplies
as well as
training for the community contamination
and crisis management
we are determined to do
all we can to support ukraine
and i welcome the concrete offers
of assistance made by allies today
at the same time
we have a responsibility to ensure the
conflict does not escalate further
because this would
be even more dangerous
and more devastating
allies agreed that we must also increase
our support for other partners at risk
from russia
at risk from russian threats and
interference including georgia and
bosnia and herzegovina
working together and with
the european union we must help them
uphold their sovereignty and strengthen
their resilience
we also addressed beijing's role in the
crisis
today allied leaders called on china
to refrain from supporting russia's war
effort
china must not provide economic or
military support
for the russian invasion instead beijing
should use its significant influence on
russia
and promote
an
immediate peaceful resolution
allies also agree that belarus must stop
acting as an accomplice to putin's
invasion
at today's meeting leaders reaffirmed
strong our strong commitment to nato's
open door policy under article 10 of the
washington treaty
nato enlargement has been an historic
success
spreading democracy freedom and
prosperity across europe
one month
since the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine
nato's security environment has
fundamentally changed for the long haul
and we are
but security but security does not come
for free
and doing war will cost more
so nato leaders agreed to re-double
efforts
to meet the defense investment pledge we
made in 2014
allies will submit additional plans on
how to meet the pledge in time for the
madrid summit in june
and i welcome that a number of allies
today announced plans for significant
increases
in defense spending
at this dangerous time transatlantic
unity and solati
are vital europe and north america are
standing and will continue to stand
strong together in nato i mean that i'm
ready to take your questions
okay cnn
hi mr secretary general thank you um
president zielinski in his address to
nato accused russia of deploying
phosphorus munitions i'm wondering
whether nato has seen evidence of that
and what your response is or would be
and then i'm wondering did you discuss
during this meeting a permanent basing
of forces in any of these countries such
as the baltics
and abandoning the nato-russia founding
act
so we are re-setting nato's returns and
defense for the long term
with more troops
with more air assets and more maritime
capabilities
we have already increased our presence
in the east and today we decided on four
new battle groups and the leaders
agreed to task our military commanders
to provide options
for a long-term reset of our
presence our military posture in the
eastern part of the alliance and across
the whole alliance
details will be then decided at our
summit
in june but that comes on top of what we
have already done so this is uh
long term we are prepared for long haul
because
we can all today say
that that
the russian invasion president putin's
invasion of ukraine
has changed our security environment
for the long term it's a new reality
it's uh
it's uh it's a new normal and nato is
responding for a long term
uh we have seen um
uh very credible reports about uh
uh the use of um
also the use of the military force
against civilians
uh and uh of course this is a great
concern uh for all nato allies
nbc
secretary general thank you for taking
my question how do you believe nato will
respond if china begins to support
russia economically and perhaps with
military supplies and also do you
believe that there's a role to play
for nato when it comes to alleviating
energy costs and i'm talking about
speaking directly to saudi arabia and
other opec producers thank you
nato allies are coordinating their
efforts when it comes to also energy
security and it was also addressed in a
meeting today
to
step up supplies to diversify
uh uh sources of supply and uh
and also also to reduce dependence on
supplies from from russia uh and uh and
later on today i also participate in the
g7 meeting and of course in different
frameworks g7 working with the eu
uh there are different formats where
nato allies address the need uh to
strengthen energy security and reduce
dependence on
on
on russian oil and
gas
our message to china is that they should
join the rest of the world and clearly
condemn
the brutal war against
ukraine
and not support uh
russia
neither with uh
with uh economic support or of course
not with military support okay we'll go
to interface ukraine late in the second
row
general news agency interface ukraine i
would like to ask you if polish
leadership put at the table today for
discussion the proposal to send
peacekeeping mission to ukraine and if
yes what kind of discussion it was and
is there is some conclusion
thank you
as we discussed a wide range of uh
issues
and
and the message is that we have to stand
united and also that we need to provide
support to ukraine but at the same time
we have a responsibility
uh to ensure that this conflict do not
become a full-fledged war
between nato and russia and
and that's also reason why allies have
may declare that we will not deploy
troops on the ground in
in ukraine
because
the only
way to do that is to be prepared to
engage in full uh conflict with
russian troops okay financial times
thank you very much secretary general
congratulations on your annual extension
um you said in the statement that allies
agreed to enhance preparedness and
readiness for chemical biological
radiological and nuclear
threats is that based on credible
intelligence that those threats could be
imminent and how does the alliance
strengthen its protection against those
threats thank you
so we are concerned uh partly because we
see the rhetoric
and we see that russia is trying to
create some kind of pretext accusing
ukraine united states nato allies for
preparing to use
chemical and biological weapons and we
have seen before that this uh
way of accusing others is actually a way
to create to create a pretext for do the
same
themselves
and of course accusations against the
ukraine and nato allies are absolutely
false
[Music]
any use of chemical
weapons will
totally change the nature of the
conflict it will be a blatant violation
of international law
and
it will have
a wide spread consequences
and of course be extremely dangerous
um
it will
affect the people in ukraine but there's
also a risk that will have a direct
effect on people living in nato
countries
because
we can see contamination we can see the
spread of um chemical agents or
biological weapons into our countries
um uh we also know that russia has used
chemical agents against its own
opposition and they have used it on nato
territory in salisbury before and we
also know that russia has facilitated
supported uh
when they used chemical weapons against
their own population
so this just highlights the importance
of
ending this war immediately because this
is a dangerous situation
and therefore we impose the sanctions so
we if we support ukraine
um
allies agreed to supply equipment to
help ukraine protect against chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats
this could include
detection
equipment protection and medical support
as well as training
for the
contamination and crisis management
we are also enhancing allies
preparedness and readiness for chemical
and biological and nuclear threats
our top military commander general
walters has activated nato's chemical
biological
radiological and nuclear
defense elements
and allies are deploying additional
chemical and biological and nuclear
defenses to reinforce our existing and
new battle groups so we are taking
measures both to support ukraine and
also to defend ourselves okay we'll go
to al jazeera
general james bayes from al jazeera
president zielinski when he addressed
you recalled the fact he first spoke to
you a month ago and he says he didn't
get clear answers
so this time he asked you specifically
for one percent of all your tanks for
one percent of all your aircraft for
multi-launch rocket systems anti-ship
weapons and means of air defense a very
specific list what is your clear answer
we all listened very carefully to
president celenski and many of the
leaders in the room uh have had contact
with him over these weeks i also spoke
with him and
under the ukrainian defenseman
participated in our defense ministerial
meeting last week we listened carefully
and of course we took note of his very
compassionate message to all nato allies
nato allies provide significant support
to ukraine
and we provide also legal weapons
advanced systems
and also systems that help them to
shoot down planes
and
attack
battle tanks with anti-tank weapons and
many other types of
of systems including drones i will not
go into the details of the exact type of
systems we are deploying this close
contact between nato allies and ukraine
but what i can say is that allies do
what they can
to support ukraine with weapons so
ukraine can defend themselves
self-defense is a right enshrined in the
eu and charter
at the same time we have a
responsibility
to
prevent this conflict from becoming a
full-fledged war in europe involving not
only ukraine and russia but uh nato
allies and russia that will be more
dangerous and more devastating and
and i think we have to be honest about
that and that's exactly what we have
been in our meeting today and also what
i say to you
in the press conference now
well what we do is that we are
delivering a lot of uh
equipment and that is an answer but i
will not go into the details i don't
think that's the wise for operational
reasons if i listed exactly what and
when and how we are delivering uh
essential equipment to ukraine nato
allies have stepped up and it's
essential for the progress they have
been able to make in the fight against
the invading russian forces thank you
very much colleagues i know there are
many questions i'm afraid the secretary
general needs to go to the g7 meeting
but there will be other briefings
throughout the day thank you so much
that was the secretary general of nato
jensen soldenberg let's just uh sum up
some of the key points he just made
first and foremost he said at the top we
stand with ukraine he agreed he said
that the nato members in their meeting
just now had agreed that they must
provide further support to ukraine and
of course touched on that point that we
discussing earlier in the show that the
leaders have now approved those four new
battle groups uh to be stationed in
slovakia hungary romania and bulgaria
and did mention there that this wasn't
just temporary aiming to reset nato's
defense and security position
for the long term so there's about a
hundred thousand nato troops across
europe uh right now and uh mentioned
that various individual member states of
nato are adding their own um further uh
help during that by the way i should
also just mention that we just had a
statement
from president biden that was released
during that press conference uh one line
that stands out on that is that nato is
as strong and united as it has ever
been he outlines uh the uh
aid to ukraine the defensive aid to
ukraine that uh the us has been involved
in uh more than a billion dollars in new
security assistance he says
anti-aircraft systems anti-armor weapons
drones and millions of rounds
of ammunition that of course over the
course of the last month not a new
billion dollars announced today and he
says he welcomes the steps by many other
allies to provide defensive support to
ukraine and together we nato are
committed to identifying additional
equipment including air defense systems
to help ukraine he like jen soldenberg
just then
also mentioned further announcements
expected and that they're planning
towards ahead of the next nato summit
in june uh just going back
uh to some of the comments from jens
stoltenberg he also said they have seen
credible reports of military force
against civilians in ukraine and
concerned by some of russia's rhetoric
that suggests they might be preparing to
use chemical weapons he made clear that
any russian claims or accusations that
the west or ukraine have been using uh
chemical western weapons themselves are
totally uh false he did say that any use
by russia of chemical weapons would
totally change the nature of this war he
mentioned the risk that those types of
weapons could affect nato countries
given the potential way that they might
spread across uh borders uh and he said
he knows that russia has used those
sorts of weapons in the past uh that was
that press conference from the nato uh
secretary general jens stoltenberg just
wrapped up moments ago alongside some
comments from uh president biden of
course uh the nato meetings may have
started to wrap up we still have a g7
meeting we still have an eu meeting so
lots more going on on the ground there
uh in in brussels throughout the rest of
this
day one of the first ukrainian refugees
to be matched with a family in england
under the government's homes for ukraine
scheme is spending her first day in
bedfordshire
hello
how are you
this was the moment that 30-year-old
ilona lemka met sarah hadley for the
first time as she touched down at
stansted airport the pair met on
facebook and applied to the government
scheme elona has been speaking to sky's
becky koshrill about feeling uh fleeing
excuse me her hometown of dinipro in
eastern ukraine and leaving her husband
and family behind
and it's it was really difficult because
you don't understand where you're going
how long time you will be absent in your
family and how long you won't see them
not only on i don't know face time or
something like that so it's difficult
because because you can help them if
something happened
and you're just crying
[Music]
it's
difficult really
yeah how was that goodbye with them
i'm already
foreign
emotional footage there uh there is
president biden of course from earlier
today uh we just mentioned some of those
headlines from uh jen stoltenberg the
secretary general of nato who just
wrapped up his press conference a press
conference is expected from president
biden later today about 7 p.m uh british
time and we did just get a statement
from him
following that meeting and uh one of the
key lines uh from that is that uh he
said nato is as strong and united uh as
ever he said immediately after russia's
uh invasion of ukraine we activated
nato's defense plans and nato response
force and the united states has surged
thousands of forces in additional
capabilities to europe and have welcomed
the new developments by our allies he
said as well of course that the united
states has announced one billion dollars
over the course of the last month in new
security assistance
to ukraine let's get to debra haynes sir
sky's security and defense editor who's
in brussels she was in that press
conference just now with jensen
stoltenberg and
deborah i i guess relatively brief uh
press conference uh the overall
tone very clear the specific
announcements perhaps uh relatively
relatively small
yes well they were always all they were
all pre-announced as well like we knew
that there was going to be these new
four new battle groups being set up um
along uh nato's eastern south eastern
flank so that's in slovakia hungary
bulgaria and romania and that's on top
of the four battle groups that have
already been
in existence since about 2015 2016
in the wake of russia's invasion of
crimea and then as well that
that announcement that nato allies had
agreed to reset their defense and
deterrence posture what does that mean
it basically means you're going to have
more troops at higher readiness more
warships more jets deployed within the
alliance along the east it's all about
showing russia readiness to act should
the alliance be attacked
nato is uh goes
out of its way to stress that it's a
defensive alliance it does not pose a
threat to russia but clearly the
defensive deterrence posture that nato
has had up until now has failed given
the fact that
russia decided it would go ahead with
its invasion of ukraine yes ukraine is
not a member of nato but one of the key
grudges that president putin has with
regards to nato is the fact that with
regards to ukraine rather is the fact
that ukraine has said it wants to join
nato and that for russia is a red line
but despite the warnings from nato to
russia not to invade it went ahead it
carried out that invasion and that's why
nato is having to have a big long look
at itself and look at how it can make
itself more fit for purpose
to ensure that
further aggression is deterred um and
then we also heard language didn't we
about the threats of a chemical attack
in ukraine it's something that the nato
allies have been warning about the
potential for um we didn't really hear
uh any kind of um consequence we heard
that there would be consequences we
heard the nato secretary general jen
stoltenberg reiterate this
this observation that would it would
change the nature of the conflict but we
don't really know exactly what that
would mean it seems like allies are
reluctant to set out a red line when it
comes to chemical weapons
maybe perhaps um back in the syria
conflict you remember back in 2013 when
the u.s did have that red line for um
russia ally president um al-assad bashar
al-assad of syria that if he were to use
um chemical weapons in his country there
would be consequences he then used
chemical weapons and there wasn't the
sort of um invasion intervention that
many had been expected to ensure that
the deterrence effect
against nations rogue nations using
chemical weapons was underlined and
that's why we're in this situation now
where we don't really know exactly how
nato would respond should russia launch
that kind of attack clearly it's
something they're talking about they
said about how they're they're giving um
ukraine uh um sort of protective
equipment and and training uh to help
them defend themselves against chemical
biological radiological even nuclear
attack these are all horrific potentials
but all potentials that they know that
russian armed the russian armed forces
have
should that conflict escalate and one
final point we heard that the ukrainian
president he addressed remotely the nato
leaders here today and in his address he
specifically asked for tanks warplanes
multi-launch rocket systems so very
serious weaponry um in order to help his
uh military in their fight for survival
against um the russian offensive and um
the the nato secretary general was asked
directly about that request and whether
or not nato had given a clear response
to that plea for help and he he didn't
want to be drawn um you could you could
get from from his answer that clearly
nato is providing critical um lethal aid
so that's anti-tank anti-air missiles
things like that defensive systems
but perhaps they are not yet ready to go
further and and support the
more offensive more aggressive weaponry
like tanks and jets um there is
potentially this invisible threshold
that nato is trying not to cross which
would then see russia regarding the nato
support for ukraine as being effectively
nato in direct confrontation on the
ground with russia and that would then
escalate this conflict beyond ukraine
and make it much more likely that it um
it balloons into something that everyone
here seems absolutely determined to
prevent and that's a full-scale war in
europe
deborah haynes uh in brussels uh thank
you so much for that summary uh busy day
of course uh of diplomacy in brussels
we're looking at uh some live pictures
right now of another family photo that's
about to take place looks like it's now
of the g7 uh members slightly smaller
group of course than this morning with a
couple of different attendees so we've
got the japanese flag in there we've got
a slavonda linen in the background there
as well uh boris johnson was in shock
just uh moments ago olaf schultz and
president biden justin trudeau in the
background and uh with this busy day of
diplomacy in brussels let's now get to
mark stone who is there and uh can look
ahead mark we've had the press
conference from the nato meeting g7 and
eu meeting to come
yes things running very very much behind
schedule uh we're here in the heart of
brussels at the in the eu quarter in the
europa building where the eu leaders
will
gather they were supposed to gather
about an hour ago um but but they're
still most of them those that are nato
members still over in uh the nato
headquarters and so um things will get
underway a little later here they're
gonna have a working dinner i think one
of the key focuses here will be
sanctions and will be energy um
if there is a split in the european
union and to be fair there really hasn't
been it's been remarkably united in how
it's dealt uh or trying to deal with the
ukraine crisis but if there is um one
area of concern then it is energy and
specifically germany which relies very
heavily on russian energy and has been
very reluctant with a couple of other
countries to sanction russia's energy
sector i don't think we will see any
sanctions on russia's energy sector
because of germany's opposition the
german chancellor has made it quite
clear as recently as yesterday that it
would literally [ __ ] the german
economy if they were to cut themselves
off from russia there's a lesson to be
learned there many say about russia's
depend
um germany's dependence on russia but i
think what we will see and what they
will have talked about at nato in the
sidelines and what we will get i think
some more detail on tomorrow is an
american plan to plug the gap so if if
russian energy is cut off then there is
a a gap that is plugged from countries
like qatar from saudi arabia from upping
the production
of oil and gas uh natural gas in america
as well so that is something that will
be discussed here as the eu leaders meet
a little later on now the president
american president will be here as well
he is the um the only non-eu um head of
government who will be attending this uh
this extraordinary eu summit as they're
calling it he'll come into this building
uh as soon as he makes his way over uh
from the nato headquarters where i think
he still is
mark stone thank you so much
this is sky news today coming up prince
william has expressed his sorrow over
slavery but stops short of an outright
apology demanded by activists in jamaica
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
independent united kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child's stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want him and that
is what it is it's first-class profit
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
prince william has expressed his
profound sorrow for slavery but stopped
short of the apology demanded by
activists in jamaica dr shola mosh
shogbamamu lawyer activist and author of
this is why i resist joins us now very
good afternoon to you good afternoon
how would you frame this
half apology or non-apology that we
heard last night uh from his royal
highness was it uh sufficient or not
enough
well first of all it was not an apology
that is not what an apology sounds like
and usually in an apology you hear the
word sorry and you could go further than
just words it to be backed up with
action
what um what we've what we've seen
prince william do is pretty much follow
the same stance that his father prince
charles and the royal family have taken
for
many many years i'm talking centuries
now including the government which is
not to apologize and take responsibility
for the actions that britain took in
conceiving executing the slave trade the
actions that it took in colonizing many
nations um and the atrocities they had
committed in that name and so what
prince william did by not apologizing
we're talking about a prince of the 21st
century he is without a doubt a product
of his time and in this time people are
clearly saying you cannot just come to
us empty-handed and that's what prince
william and catherine have done they've
gone to these countries empty-handed
they must have known fully well the
temperature they should have known the
temperature of people in jamaica in in
the bahamas in belize they should have
gone with the full intention of making
of making amends and that goes a long
way to demonstrating the intent of the
royal family and this government in that
in righting wrongs and that's that's
what they failed to do
you mentioned uh the government there as
well does the responsibility to
apologize for these historic wrongs
lie mainly at the feet of his royal
highness the duke of cambridge or on
others on many more people on all of us
definitely all of us but remember that
it is the royal family that started off
that started off cons with the
conception of slave trade as a business
in this country and that its own
parliament its parliament executed it
and for
centuries britain as a nation benefited
from exploiting all of these nations
that were colonized it committed
atrocities in genocide it is the same
britain that apologized and paid
slave owners if it could apologize and
pay slave owners how can it not
apologize and pay the slaves and
descendants of the slaves and this is
what we are talking about we are not
looking and people are not looking
whether it's activists campaigners or or
people from from these nations nobody is
looking for lip service and that's what
we're getting from prince william lip
service is what we're getting from um
from the government is what we're
getting from the queen remember that the
queen is meant to be head of state
which is why she's been removed now
because when you look at what the queen
has done as head of state of these
nations i think if you were going to do
a performance review on her you would
fail her i mean look at what happened
with the windrush generation
the queen never stepped in to say you
must treat this my the subjects my
subjects in this nations equally to the
way you would treat my white subjects in
the united kingdom she didn't step in to
do anything for them they're not treated
equally so how has she actually done
anything on behalf of this nation this
is why they're looking to remove her as
head of state it is also why it's saying
that the slave trade cannot just be
swept under the carpet because britain
is still benefiting from the wealth and
resources that it exploited for many of
these nations and it helped to put
britain on the map on the on on the
global map as an economic power and as a
military power so yeah there's that as
far as i'm concerned it is now the time
to pay reparations and it's more than
not enough time for the royal family and
this government to say we are sorry
thank you so much for joining us here on
sky news today
you're watching sky news uh coming up
with sarah jane next hour a day of
diplomacy western leaders meet to
discuss what more they can do to help
ukraine on this month anniversary of the
war
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you